hans isn't afraid to change with the
boys we found out with about your three
and a half right is that what you said
three and a half inches three and a half
four and a half and a half five and a
half oh okay american average
[Laughter]
asian massive yeah
in asia that's called a black [ __ ] uh
five and a half inches holy [ __ ] and
what's it do hans we never really ask
you about your love life what kind of
girls are you into you into asian girls
i find that a lot of asian guys are into
asian girls they they're set to default
quite often and they just go with what
they know i mean who isn't into asian
girls they're like the best
they're soft
they're small
and they do what they tell what do they
do what you tell them to do
[Laughter]
well we found out a lot about hans kim
he he's dating a girl right now uh
that's a comedian is that true oh
trying to pursue a comedian right now
how's that working out is it going good
very terribly i took her to a strip club
oh that's right we did talk about this
last week that's incredible have you
made any moves with her since then
i mean we're cool now like i think uh
we're cool now so
we're not gonna take her to any more
strip clubs have you gotten a land have
you landed a kiss on or anything like
that or are you like dale and mendoza
and just eating rolled ice cream and
[ __ ] it up
i'm like i'm like jalen
[Applause]
when's the last have you ever been with
a white girl before yes
uh
yeah i mean i used to date a white girl
for six months
uh white girls are plentiful around
america
but uh
thank you hans i had no idea i just got
here
super recently
very excited to find that out that white
girls are plentiful here
happenstance would have it that that's
uh
very interesting
i love it guys this is your first time
seeing hans kim right these are both uh
these the uh paulie is uh i don't want
to say anything there's an asian with
you on stage i'm scared no it's a good
thing
it's a good thing this is one of the
good ones paulie gotta be nice to these
[ __ ] dude seriously this is one of
the good this is one of the good ones
you know you know that's a rowdy rowdy
race but uh
this is one of the good ones uh
well wait a second wait a second i'm
changing my mind about him here hold on
i love it hans famously sang the
national anthem to kick off the first
kill tony back from my cancellation
two weeks after my cancellation
super cancelled
[Applause]
all my buddies are like it'll blow over
dude just take a few months off it'll
all be good i'm like ah how about two
weeks
i'm gonna have hans kim sing the
national anthem trust me it'll be fine
they're like what then i hung up the
phone
was it like the national anthem of like
north korea no i had no i had him sing
the american national anthem he had to
read from pieces of paper but uh
we we got through it took a while but we
got through it
so hans what do you think it's gonna
take for you to bang this uh american
white girl comedian that you're into
probably uh testosterone uh
you think if we brought her on stage
right now that she'd give you a big kiss
have you kissed her yet
have you kissed her hans look at me have
you kissed her yet you haven't kissed
her on the list i don't think she's here
really
how about another white girl you want to
kiss another wife yes is there a white
girl out there that wants to kiss hans
cam
anybody we have a great fan base here i
see a lot of beautiful women out there
someone want to come down here and come
on get come downstairs you dirty
[Applause]
we're about to have some fun someone is
someone coming down
is someone coming down oh d madness is
going to do it everybody
this is crazy d madness doesn't give a
[ __ ] whoa here comes one right here look
at this
hit it
oh [ __ ] come on
[Applause]
holy [ __ ] all right stop what the [ __ ]
my instagram is mila baby underscore xo
i'm a dancer in miami hold on hold on
wait we can't hear you are you from
miami did you take a [ __ ] in front of
the last guy
no i did it i'm half orlando where did
you come from were you were you born on
rainy street what happened here
she looks like she just walked out of
bangers like that no i just i just
i'm a [ __ ]
[Applause]
[Music]
oh my god
my mom my mind is completely blown
for those of you just listening to the
podcast you're [ __ ] up man
this chick was trying to say goodbye and
hans went in for round two and took it
right to the dome
hans kim you are a badass [ __ ]
thank you
please i have more to offer your south
korean parents would be so
disappointed if they could see what you
were doing here in wild texas if you had
white parents they'd be so proud but
your
south korean parents would be very
dishonored about uh you just making out
with random white chicks with extremely
hard people by the way
jesus christ
looks like she already has a couple
fortune cookies in her bra waiting for
you hans
those things were ruckus
oh
my god hans
that was awesome hell yeah
i don't know she seems wild i i think
you went from hot and sour to cold sore
[Laughter]
there's gonna be a big something popping
up
you know what's cool what's the girl
that you like what's her name
the girl that you talked about before
isabella charlton wow
she's gonna see that and you're gonna
get some [ __ ] because of that dude
[Applause]
yo that chick that was on stage was hot
as [ __ ] bro i don't know about that is
there any chance isabella's here
isabella if you're here come to this
stage let's have a talk with isabella
that's the girl that he likes isabel are
you here
is it really happening come to the stage
come to the stage
holy [ __ ] isabella charlton is here
everybody
holy [ __ ]
yeah
holy [ __ ]
what a magical episode of kill tony
first of all isabella
a great comedian she was on the show
last week she's been on the show
numerous times famously from england as
a funny take on our [ __ ] country i
cannot wait to hear to find out to see
what she thinks about this hans kim
situation isabella first of all
remind us all isabella are you currently
single
yeah whoa
that's a good start okay isabella
uh hand isabella the microphone hans
isabella what do you think about all
that's happening right now
i can't tell whether you have no idea
what the [ __ ] going on or if you're
really disappointed that hans kissed a
smurf before you came up here kiss him
kiss him kiss him right guys kiss him
kiss him kiss him
[ __ ] up [ __ ] isabella what's your
situation you ever kissed an asian guy
before
have you ever kissed an asian guy look
you're in america in hong kong yeah
listen you [ __ ] brit you're in
america right now you're gonna answer
our questions yeah lock the [ __ ]
doors you have kissed an asian guy right
yeah wait we talked to you last week
didn't you say that you dated an asian
gay guy i grew up in hong kong i did an
asian guy i did an eurasian guy oh [ __ ]
okay so what do you think hans is a good
looking guy i'm genuinely disgusted in
him as a person and he knows that
why are you disgusted by the way
take it from me you can't say that any
type of asian person's disgusting
anymore uh i happen to know this for a
fact my grandmother called me and uh
she told me that i [ __ ] up so
what are you disgusted in isabella help
us to understand what's going on right
now his behavior i can't even believe i
i think that girl that was here should
come on stage and kiss [ __ ] her bro
oh [ __ ] here she is
oh
wait wait wait wait wait wait wait wait
wait wait kiss hands again
[Applause]
oh my god oh my god
what in the world is hans going in for
for
hans just keeps trying
[Music]
[Laughter]
what what are you saying
it's the tequila sure don't make any
excuses
hans has been drinking [ __ ] sake all
night excited about this
isabella i mean look at this this is a
pretty [ __ ] good-looking chick coming
up here and taking your uh taking your
dinner right from you
isabella what do you think about this oh
i'm so upset oh no
oh no don't carry him away
[Laughter]
don't put him in your pocket and run
it appears as though she wants to make
out with both of you so badly i don't
know
isabella's like [ __ ] no i'll be i'll
i'll bet your red band gives you a spot
on thursday at is i mean isabella if you
want to spot on thursday uh i'm doing a
show here on wednesday oh
you can open up for paulie you can do
the death squad show
i have covered oh she has covet
everybody there you go uh i love it what
are you two hold on uh isabella come
back over to hans just stand on the
other side of them it's okay
you can't you you can't catch whatever
she has just by standing close to her uh
she just gave me the middle finger i
wanted to put a condom on it uh
so that nothing
nothing spreads hans is like don't let
him talk to you like that
i'll protect you
they are just making out
you sue by the way
by the way right now hans is like
isabella who
thank god
oh my god he went from [ __ ] hogwarts
to [ __ ] warts over here
yes
this is skill tony
all right time to [ __ ] there he goes
hans kim everybody
isabella thank you so much
isabella
isabella take one of those just for a
souvenir
hans coming off a big big episode last
week where uh he got to kiss a girl i
asked if there was a girl in the
audience and uh and
like a like a like a austin 10 came on
stage
totally like not even kiss you guys like
went to it and i heard i i guess i left
but i heard hans puked in five different
places in vulcan that night well
i only saw one he famously puked in the
trash can it was a lot right we were we
were laughing pretty hard at that but
let's talk about the other four places
that was that true were there multiple
places i puked in the sink
uh in that bathroom i puked on the
sidewalk look at you
hell yeah just marking your territory
[ __ ]
that's actually uh how coronavirus got
started yeah that's true
hans is originally from wuhan not a lot
of people know that
wuhan's very own
hans kim
incredible
uh so that was fun and then when you
admit you made out with a girl and then
you just kept making out with her over
and over again it was very incredible
we loved it the crowd went absolutely
wild because hans is such an innocent
he's such a good person and he's such an
innocent guy uh have you uh made out
with anybody since then no
that's a shame you know what
is there a woman out in the audience
that wants to come up and why don't we
have someone
[Music]
listen let me let me just say something
real quick is that kill tony famously
has the greatest fans in the world i
mean look at us on a monday
270 people deep here
i'm positive i'm gonna ask one more time
it always works we've never had no way
can i just interrupt for one second sure
the last time he kissed a girl he threw
up five times is there a guy that wants
to make out
yeah there's gonna be a lot of guys that
want to do that
almost every single man in this room
wants to hey there's another asian guy i
just noticed you right now
look at this [ __ ] you were there the
whole time
yeah and you guys are like silent polite
people i literally didn't even notice
you there
stealthy incredible it's incredible you
guys are special special good people
really good people the asian people um
i'm gonna switch it back there has to be
a woman out there that wants to give
hans kim a big kiss
guys he's one of the funniest people
[Applause]
there's got to be someone
come on down come down that
staircase this chick's just waving from
a balcony
is she coming
oh wow
[Music]
hello you stay right there i want to
talk with you
oh my god hans kim just got to make out
with the bride of chucky i love it
this is incredible
thank you welcome to the show
of course i love this i just want to
hold you by the shoulders and blow all
those hairs off your head like a
dandelion
very sweet oh look at this incredible
absolutely this is wild i happen to know
hans is a big fan of eminem so he got to
knock two things off his bucket list
tonight i'm close enough to a man right
you are adorable what's your name my
name is katie hi katie welcome to the
show how are you i'm well what brought
you here tonight i'm on a date oh really
hell yeah dude
hell yeah
with hans kim now
oh [ __ ]
was hans a good kisser actually not bad
yeah that's what a lot of people are
saying control that's why
you're what i took control that's why
that's right that's right what does he
taste like sweet and sour he actually it
tastes bad
refreshing that's great hans has a
[ __ ] sun tan look at the controversy
stripper you're a stripper can i get a
job wait a second where are you what
what pet store are you a stripper at
exactly i wear i wear a wig when i strip
what i wear a wig when i [ __ ] really
yeah what's your stripper name my name
is tara
tara can i plug my only fans
sure why not absolutely [ __ ] yeah um
it's onlyfans.com
tara's world 21. all right there you go
naked
what's the craziest thing that you do on
your only fans is there any uh are there
any like what they do you just i don't
want to guess you just tell us
i the most recent post you do get to see
[ __ ]
wow
look at that red band already subscribed
[Laughter]
absolutely incredible now do you have to
pay a couple dollars extra for creamy
content or anything like that for you
it's free
redband turn off your microphone
okay
so this date that you're on is this the
first date that you're on tonight nah
it's like the third or fourth okay so
you guys have like hooked up and
everything yeah of course okay so what
do you think this guy's gonna say about
you i asked before okay i'm polite all
right
okay and he said he said go right ahead
during this go ahead during this
pandemic go make out with a uh
i love it you guys are dirty of course
um
wow you seem like a wild wild girl right
yeah uh what's the most wild sexual
thing you've ever done
oh i've had sex in the hallway of a
cruise
whoa
like the roof the main like rooms
hallway where the room you know where
it's all lit up and anyone can walk by
yeah oh [ __ ] dude how long did that last
not long no the guy finished quickly
yeah he came on himself yeah that makes
sense after 20 seconds you have to come
on yourself of course everyone knows you
have to last at least five minutes to
come on the other person you got to earn
it yeah it's a real you have to punish
yourself that's how you learn the lesson
the hard way
like i'm [ __ ] up i'm sorry
hans what's the longest you've uh what's
the longest you've lasted with a girl
sexually you seem like the kind of guy
that uh finishes in 40 minutes or less
for sure
uh probably about 15 minutes whoa 15
minutes not long enough wow what would
we have to do to get hans in the bedroom
with you in this date that you're with
tonight
oh i love bisexual men the guy i'm with
is
up
he might be up for something oh [ __ ]
really why don't we call him down here
get the date down here let's see what's
going on
here he comes the guy that brought
[Music]
here he comes everybody
oh [ __ ] here we go oh [ __ ] dude
oh
[ __ ]
hell yeah bro
[Applause]
what's up my man welcome welcome you
guys are adorable look at this [ __ ]
crew
i feel like i'm looking through a
microscope and i'm seeing chlamydia
[Applause]
protection is necessary
i love this [ __ ]
oh
[ __ ]
what's your name sir my name is jonah
what is it jonah
like the whale like the whale jonah and
the whale jonah you got muncha cheese on
you that's awesome
okay
there you go red man with a little shirt
commentary at the at the mat points
where it matters the most everybody
there you go weird red man noticed
there you go no truly no one gives a
[ __ ] uh
i love it so this is your guys like
third fourth fifth date something like
that you guys have been banging it out
something like that my god i bet you
guys have the weirdest pubic hairs am i
correct you guys have like die jobs down
there it looks like this of course your
shape
looks like this and you and you sort of
swing you like have sex with almost
anything right is that true there's a
rumor going around you want to find out
no no i don't want to find out no
[Applause]
we'll be right back after these messages
here on kill tony i'm kidding we don't
have commercial breaks
i love it can we get a can we get a
tally on piercings you've got three in
your nose you've got one on your nose
what do you got there
you're allowed to show up if you if you
go if you fade if you face that way
there you go there's
like
no video recording sir look at this guy
over here okay okay that's enough jesus
christ
my god
what the [ __ ] do you think's going on
over here
i turned back around she's giving greg a
lap dance
so
one two three
four
five
and how many on you just the one okay
that's it
you don't have your uh little ding dong
you want to find out prince albert no i
have an iud that would not be good
speaking of ding dong let's check back
in with hans kim over here
what do you think about this
good-looking couple it's like uh it's
like uh i don't know what it's like uh
it's like danger mouse or something like
that right
what's the band with the crazy polish
chick it's like a
what's the [ __ ] one uh
d ant word thank you so much hell yeah
we'll edit that in where i said uh
danger mouse
it'll get a big laugh we'll put a huge
laugh in there um
so uh hans what do you think about this
what either you think you could spend
the night with [ __ ] uh
damn oh [ __ ]
[Applause]
i love it when hans plays back it's so
weird
i think they're like a great
experimental adventurous american couple
and if you'd like to teach this young
asian boy your american ways
and then we'll talk about it next week
you'll give us
hans you'll give us the full update next
week for sure all right ladies and
gentlemen that's it on scam everybody
one more time for the whole group
they're
gonna [ __ ] tonight
oh my god they put the six nine in
takashi six nine
it's like takashi 6-9 meets order number
69
oh my god wow i think i'm going to throw
up five times
look at hans hans is running for the
back door right now
now hans is smiling ear to ear he's good
enough to drink more screwball peanut
butter whiskey so that he could man up
and do that [ __ ]
that guy's gonna drink peanut butter
whiskey and then he's gonna eat a man's
ass tonight
hans famously uh made out with a girl
this is that was the second week in a
row where
a random female audience member came to
the stage you made out with her and then
afterwards i heard about this
immediately afterwards during the
elusive and uh highly rumored about kill
tony after parties that sometimes happen
he had sex with her in the broom closet
everybody yeah
hell yeah
yeah but tony he didn't tell you that
that guy also had sex with him in the
broom closet that's a joke that's what
that's where red band throws in a wacky
joke but i thought that was no one had
sex with my dear boy hans kim i would
never let another man mate with hans
uh
but no you had sex with this girl let's
talk about it how was it she was a
little uh firecracker she had the little
butch haircut it was a whole thing she
was very energetic and enthusiastic
how did you know like what what stood
out as energetic and enthusiastic to you
well we did a little doggy style we did
mostly doggy style hell yeah hell yeah
did you eat the dog afterwards
no i'm kidding go ahead i'm sorry
low-hanging fruit low hanging fruit i'm
sorry you thought i would have learned
by now
and uh she she did the thing uh where
she backs into it and like does a little
circle motion whoa
hell yeah professional
yeah the old [ __ ] ass tornado i've
seen that before
michael
i would just
like to say
now more than ever
i hate hans
um yeah um
i moved here
for that
[Music]
and
the biggest surprises
being a worker is more of a deer breaker
than being asian
michael
yeah michael has not got to have sex in
the broom closet however once uh the
janitor did think he was a mop and
bucket wow
it's the closest to having sex in a
broom closet there's no ramp into the
broom closet that's true there's always
steps to the broom closet
uh
so hans
tell me more how did it finish what was
the uh what happened when you uh when
you climaxed like what was that like
exactly was that that during the was
that during the doggy style or the ass
spinning like what does it take what
does it take to make a guy like hans kim
come
so there was the ass spinning in the
beginning and then it was just straight
back and forth linear uh oh linear okay
okay geograph
geometrically [ __ ] regular sex okay
how long did you last
it was like 60 seconds there was a sound
of a cat
go ahead well how long did you last i
would say like five minutes oh good
that's respectful that's pretty good for
in a broom closet yeah normally like
broom closet sex the guy comes
immediately because you're thinking wow
what a dirty girl this is right
this is so wrong and that's exactly how
most guys come
i think that's what most guys are into
do you remember like what your sounds
and face look like when you came
tony i'm sorry i did it again that part
might get edited out i'm gonna be honest
with you just kidding i always just say
that nothing gets uttered at all
maybe we'll beep that part we'll beep it
and put a blur over my face because i
went cross-eyed for no reason
that's insulting
uh now what was it like how did you come
what was it like i was uh
doing the linear motion and then she uh
she she disembarked and oh wow i didn't
realize she was on a cruise ship this
whole time
and then she started uh giving me a
little [ __ ]
with the condom on whoa oh
she kept the condom on yeah that means
she knows something you should you don't
want to know wait why don't you have a
condom on okay
she wanted a condom take it off let's
just all soak it in let's slow it down
and then after the blow job was over i
still want to know the answer to his
question did you put the condom on or
did she put the condom on you originally
she was insistent on the condom
oh
okay
so we were in the closet and then we got
trapped in it we couldn't open the door
so then i called my buddy ridge ridge
and he came and opened the door and i
was like dude do you have a condom and
he's like yeah here you go i was like
dude you're the best holy [ __ ] really
what's that came into the janitor's
closet yeah by the way it's incredible i
have never in my life heard of condom
sex in the janitor's closet right that's
like the opposite yeah the fact that you
had sex with such a dirty girl in such a
what should be a clean place is uh
incredible and you had clean sex in a
dirty place it's all like mind-blowing
if you think about it you like broke the
matrix of dirty hookups at a bar venue
and then she wouldn't let me finger her
in the parking lot yesterday
red band is insistent on knowing i just
want to know
on what your face is like when you come
show the audience look right at that
camera right across there and show us
your [ __ ] face
[Music]
[Laughter]
wow it was worth it well
i mean incredible to know all this
information but you know there's still a
part of me that
wants to keep this momentum going i
think we can do better
the first week he made out with a girl
the second week he made out with her on
the stage and then after the show had
sex in a broom closet let's see what
happens this week is there a kill tony
fan out there is there a lady out there
that wants to come up and start a new
segment called monday night with hans
maybe start a family this time every
week there's always a beautiful girl
that comes down sometimes from the
balconies sometimes from down here how
many do you think we should get a girl
up here to make out with hans tonight
this guy doesn't seem to think so huh
this [ __ ] tough guy
drove all the way from round rock to be
here tonight has no idea where he is
right now it's like what's up with all
these [ __ ] talking about sex
well uh actually i uh i brought a date
to tonight's show so
what
what the [ __ ] are you doing man and that
was that was that was hans's existence
as a regular everybody was that
you brought a date yeah well why doesn't
she come down and make out with you then
well
that's a good point
get down here
where is she this is taking too long
hans don't bring a [ __ ] date to kill
tony
oh look it's my dad oh [ __ ]
look at this easy hoe
hey it's paige
wait oh
[Music]
hold on hold on stop stop stop
let me tell you something
i got to tell you that's not good this
whole bring a date to kill tony things
some [ __ ] this chick probably knows
that if she goes on a date with you on a
monday that she gets that's the laziest
kiss i've seen out of all the kisses the
past few weeks that's like a sponsor
that we don't get paid for
yeah that kiss was [ __ ] i
i mean take your shirt off and kiss him
wait wait unless everybody's no no no
don't do that don't do that stop stop
stop red man can you chill a little bit
how much red bull did you have before
tonight's [ __ ] show hold on hans what
the [ __ ] is a date on how did where how
did you start this date what happened
here where did you guys [ __ ] we met
on instagram oh god
hans you are such a [ __ ] pushover
met on instagram who met who how did
this happen
uh do you want to tell them
no i don't want her to talk right now
i'm pretty sure this is all her plans
unfolding
that's exactly what she wants you to say
and she's gonna make some [ __ ] shitty
joke if you put that mic in front of her
face
she invited me to a jason marazz concert
just randomly on instagram out of
nowhere yeah she it was like uh so she's
a fan of the show
she she saw it once and was uh does she
know the show do you know the show i had
a friend show me yeah so that's a yes
okay is there another girl in the
audience that'll come down here
well hans is on a [ __ ] date and
shohans show this girl what a real kiss
looks like on a monday night i'm gonna
wait until it happens
[Music]
i'm going to [ __ ] wait
i know a miracle will happen here
[Music]
that girl
did not think it was gonna go that way
no tony yes michael um the army
the irony is
this one i think she wants to come up
yes come on up here
put your
this is the greatest show in the world
and you are at it right now
yes
[Applause]
look at this
[Music]
[Applause]
yes
oh
[ __ ]
[Music]
dude oh my god
wow that is abs hans date came to an
abrupt end just now
[Laughter]
and to the broom closet we go
hey thank you sweetheart you're a legend
what's your name
how about a hand for alyssa everybody
hans this is taking way too long but i
gotta ask you how do you feel i feel
amazing
tony should we get the date back up to
see what she feels about this
no i don't think so
i don't think so
maybe she can go off to a jason mraz
concert or
something like that but
bring a date on your monday night show
michael what do you think about um you
know i'm in the handicapped bathroom
before this show i [ __ ] hans just
steve
hans is what dude
oh
okay
michael fuckton's day this is gonna be
the first podcast that has subtitles on
it ladies and gentlemen uh for those of
you listening just use the braille app
on your iphone uh
i love it um
hans you're a [ __ ] legend what a
great way to get the show started thank
you so much hans kim ladies and
gentlemen
and it has begun
wow that was awesome
the show's completely improvised if you
haven't noticed i didn't know hans was
on a date by the way hans owes paying a
lot of [ __ ] like respect if it wasn't
for peng
well i mean no i don't you know i don't
i'm not exactly sure about that i think
hans could have easily become a regular
even without all that crazy [ __ ]
happening he's amazing how about one
more time for hans kim ever yeah
and i think i think there's a girl
coming up hold on a second are we about
to make kills
wait there's two of them
oh [ __ ]
oh my god
wait what about that one
yes
[Music]
[Applause]
[Music]
holtzman giving girls highlighters
trying to get part of the action here
wow about me too me too ladies ladies
kiss me
too
please say under the microphone what are
your names
jennifer jennifer and i'm stormy stormy
everybody how about that hell yeah
stormy just made out with tsunami over
here i love it
[Applause]
my [ __ ] goodness great and you ladies
work at the yellow rose
i'm telling you best [ __ ] strip club
they even have a sense of humor over
there i love it
[ __ ] yeah look at hans just trying to
[ __ ] speed date as fast as they can
so what do you do where are you from
where do you where do you order your
hobbies what do you like to do uh yeah
where is your favorite place to eat uh
you want to go there want to go there
you like vans do you like vans huh you
like vanilla broom closet yeah i bet
[Applause]
hell yeah what would you ladies do with
a guy like hans kim if you had him alone
in his van in the back of the van what
would you uh what would be your first
move
[Laughter]
yeah i think we would read
oh okay well i guess you'd have to learn
how to do that first how about how about
stormy stormy what would be your first
movement some private dances something
fun oh [ __ ] look at that hans i think i
think tonight might be oh look at that
little celebratory dance that confirms
it he's asian everybody uh
ladies i love that you came down here
thank you so much for making out with my
friend
these are the lovely ladies of the
yellow rose
[ __ ] wait are you going in for another
one hans look at this this is one of
han's greatest tricks is going in for a
second makeup
little pat on the back there for the
road i guess
little good luck guys give it up for the
yellow and the red rose
unbelievable
our most loyal [ __ ] local sponsor
since day one god how hot were those
ladies it's unbelievable i mean that
place it's a no-brainer to go there and
i'm sure hans is gonna show up there uh
real soon uh hans did you have fun
tonight i had a blast
these experiences here on kill tony how
do you describe this new life of yours i
would describe it as like exhilarating
and sexually liberating absolutely i
love it he's wise with his words and
another killer minute ladies and
gentlemen to start the show how about
hans kim everybody huh
so hans famously you have been kissing
hot girls on this show for the last five
i believe five weeks in a row
this week we have had made i don't know
if you've ever seen anything quite like
this before but this is an i kissed hans
kim
official kill tony
t-shirt
so i don't know
even though you're on a [ __ ] date for
some reason
on a show where you're notoriously a
[ __ ]
[Music]
i don't know i figured maybe i'd give
the shirt out if there was a girl out
there in the audience that wanted to
come up and make out with hans kim
oh han
we've never seen hawks call his shot
like this
hans is pulling a babe ruth right now
wait a second i don't think come on
maybe she doesn't want to is that what
it is do you think i'm ugly are you
going to come on stage and shove your oh
no
this way she just dab come on come on
oh [ __ ] it's me
wait that wasn't a real kill that was a
real kiss that wasn't a real kiss no no
no get back up here
no get up here get up here that wasn't
real is it real come up and get coming
she can go back to [ __ ] sisty texas
without attitude
[Applause]
[Music]
that's a shitty cast
huh that was the most awkward [ __ ] i've
ever seen in my life no jimmy hold on a
second let me take over here for a
second
i have never in the history of the show
seen weaker kisses from girls
than these two kisses that i is there a
girl in this audience that wants to come
up here and [ __ ] make out with hans
kim
there's gotta be a hero yeah come up
here and play a game but tons of hockey
with this kid
what kind of [ __ ] is this do you have an
only fans to promote this is a good time
someone's gonna get this t-shirt
there seems to be some movement from up
there someone's coming okay all right
you're gonna see maybe his date will
come down a month ago
hans wasn't getting any girls to kiss
him at all and now it's a weekly ordeal
this guy knows how to make out too
is this happening yeah
they just oh [ __ ]
oh [ __ ] dude
oh get the [ __ ] out of here oh get the
[ __ ] out of here
that ain't right oh [ __ ]
wow
[Laughter]
good god oh my god
holy [ __ ]
here you go
god damn
god damn i sucked the lug nuts off the
truck that drove her panties wait wait
wait get back up here hold on a second
hold on you're one of my favorite
characters wait who is chick
you have to make out with hans too if
you want to come up here
[Applause]
[Music]
[Applause]
[Music]
[Applause]
oh my god
all right all right all right everybody
settle down
all right all right
hans is gonna wake up with a load of
potato flakes in his pubes tomorrow
morning
there's nothing funnier to me right now
than the disappointed face of the virgin
sitting right here in the front just
like you gotta be [ __ ] kidding me man
wow
god damn you ladies are cool as hell how
does it feel making out with hans grab
this microphone
it feels great wow you want to do a
minute it's clean right it's clean you
want to do a couple minutes
no jimmy no don't ask me to do stand up
no jimmy
[ __ ] the guests always start misbehaving
when the hot chicks make out with hansen
this is a new weekly ordeal i'm [ __ ] i'm
i'm stiffer to the gay shell or ricky
martin concert right now bro
jesus christ a gay sailor hit a ricky
martin
oh my god
are these yellow rings from the yellow
rose red rose yes wow
this is what i'm talking about now we'll
cook them with gas
unbelievable the best [ __ ] strip club
most beautiful women ever it is
incredible [ __ ] hans how do you feel
right now
i feel like i have to contain myself
right now
well that's what the van is for later
when you're when you're you can picture
try to remember their faces when you're
[ __ ] the girl that uh that you're on
this
boring ass date on tonight
it's a good thing he's wearing his
sponge underpants i'll tell you that
yeah
asians are good at math so let me tell
you two tens is better than a six uh
[Applause]
[Music]
i love it my favorite is looking at the
faces of the women that know they're not
tens just like
and then they realize i'm looking at
them and then they fake laugh
well they're more than welcome to join
us tonight hey
look at that
hell yeah
what do you think can we get her to
confirm will you let these ladies join
come on down yeah kiss the girls jesus
christ
[Music]
ivor this is why we are the greatest
live podcasts in the world
here
in austin texas austin texas now let me
remind you none of this is set up
this is the actual girl
[Applause]
oh my god
[Music]
wait a second
[Applause]
[Music]
[Applause]
[Music]
[Applause]
[Music]
this is incredible all right what about
the other girl what about the other girl
wait what about this one
far away it's a far away
all right all right all right all right
all right all right all right all right
i just killed tony this is jerry
springer what's going on bro i love it
what's going on this is [ __ ] kill
boney everybody in the room's heart is a
rock right now
look at the look on hans kim's face
everybody
wow
look at this i like your date now your
data is a good sense of humor
how many you think huns should [ __ ] all
of them tonight yeah
all right
that's it
the orders have been given make the fans
proud hans
yeah an hour and a half after they [ __ ]
them they're gonna be horny again
this is the most [ __ ] an asian man has
ever gotten
[Laughter]
ladies and gentlemen guys this was a
brand new minute and an interview with
the great austin zone hans kim everybody
[Applause]
wow
yikes
oh my god he's still going
oh my god
he's get he's gonna kiss them all on
their way out
[Applause]
[Music]
[Applause]
oh my god
wow
[Music]
wow
wow
come on one more time for hans kim
everybody oh yeah
you're gonna have to explain to your
grandkids one day when you're showing
them this video
you're gonna be like i swear there was a
global pandemic going on
it didn't make any sense
there's more [ __ ] antibodies on this
stage right now than there's a chinese
phone book
thank you red band
thank you red band for putting that
cherry on top jesus does it become a
problem when you want to [ __ ]
i can tell you we've asked him that it
is not a problem joe
turns out a lot of ladies like making
their way back to that van
if they even make it there you know hans
famously had sex with a girl in a broom
closet here at vulcan gas company just a
few weeks ago
he's on a streak right now every single
week a beautiful woman has come out of
the audience no one knows where or who
it's going to be they randomly just do
it and they come up and they make out
with innocent old hans who before coming
uh
before becoming a full-time cast member
of the show had a pretty slow moving sex
life
yes how much has it changed
i mean uh yeah i mean it's changed a lot
you know
[Laughter]
yeah before it was hard are you getting
[ __ ] just from this show
you don't have to answer that
i don't like the way you phrased that
we have these new shirts that have been
made uh
[Applause]
the dragon the dragons
there's a beautiful girl out there in
the audience that wants to come up and
you have to really make out with hans
though he's a serious kisser
no pecs allowed this is hilarious it's
cool right
hold on a second lower the music for a
second and if that doesn't work if
there's a male that brought his
girlfriend uh
[Music]
[Applause]
the brand new my girl kissed hans kim
shirts are now for sale that did happen
right
huh that did happen oh yeah
if so if there's a girl out there
is there a girl that wants to come up
and make out with hans kim everybody oh
here comes someone i do believe
they're making a hand signal there's
lighting i see professional lighting for
some reason
oh
lol
hans looks like you got another heavy
workload in front of you
[Laughter]
[Applause]
[Laughter]
[Applause]
[Music]
[Applause]
come on guys make some noise hans kim
living his dreams
[Applause]
oh my god jesus christ
all right that's two oh wow
oh jesus
christ
[Music]
i don't feel good
this is out of control tony you only
have one shirt i know i don't have
enough shirts for all of this and uh
you guys know there's a pandemic
[Laughter]
[Applause]
and guess who started it
[Laughter]
it was han
it was han
[Music]
absolutely incredible my guess is that
these are the ladies of the yellow rose
and the red rose am i right wow
look at this look what it's become
hans you get the most beautiful girls to
come down here and kiss you every single
week it's absolutely incredible
yes uh please
this can happen outside kill tony too
you know if you see me on the street
say hello
[Laughter]
oh
what the [ __ ]
hans you have no limit to your [ __ ]
did you girls know about this before you
got here did you notice yeah
oh yeah
do they pay you to do this
you got a free house for a week to do
this
yeah we have a big budget here kill tony
what'd you say
cody up there the general manager of the
yellow rose
i love it that is so cool well you girls
are lovely and he's very happy amazing
turn look at him i've never seen a man
so happy look at this
anybody else
anybody that says that's bad is lying
hans is now a wonderful thing look at
him hans does this very special thing
joe where we've seen this it's all come
in his pants
[Laughter]
[Applause]
cause that's what i'm saying look at him
he's embarrassed he looks lighter he
does a very special thing where he tries
to sneak more kisses in when the girls
look at him if you look if you look
closely anytime one of the girls look at
him he starts slowly moving in for
another kiss hans hans who was your
favorite uh out of the three uh oh my
god
you son of a [ __ ]
you
you first yeah you [ __ ] block the man
first you [ __ ] block him and then you
put him up against the wall i'm smiling
look at that smile i feel like stormy
and i have a relationship now yeah
just in terms of we i've kissed her
three times now on the show wow wow yeah
it's really it used to be random
audience members stormy keeps coming
down i think stormy likes the tsunami
you know what i'm saying
i did that joke a couple weeks ago but
it's worth doing it again
how about uh how about this little uh
khaleesi looking character if uh
khaleesi's hot yeah that's a comment
she's the queen of dragons she was bad
that's her dragon right there yeah
that's your dragon it was an honor to
kiss the mother of dragons
[Laughter]
she's very expert with the tongue
[Music]
i've yet to learn about that technique
so i hope we can have some private
sessions
oh my god i love it hans you're
legitimately nervous this is adorable
look at him i'm nervous joe look at this
[ __ ]
it is the absolute best the yellow rose
and the red rose has the most amazing uh
beautiful and charismatic strippers in
this very nice ladies and uh it is
incredible house fees for everyone
for everyone house fees
when
when they first said house fees i
thought they had to live in his house
in his van yeah i got nervous he has van
fees so they're all
they all have the same thing going on
very good hans uh what do you think
where does the night go from where does
the night go after this i mean we still
have the after party um so
maybe we should hang out more uh
i could tell you some of the jokes i was
gonna do but i didn't do here so
look at that look at the girl next to
you hans her chest is like your report
card all a's
[Applause]
still got it
oh come on
[Music]
i just got the middle finger on that one
we're having fun i'm just goofing are
you make a living off those [ __ ]
things hell yeah absolutely absolutely
very good
you and hans can compare all night long
uh i'm kidding i'm kidding i'm kidding
welcome to the show hans did you have
fun tonight yes i did are you living
are you living your dreams here on kill
tony yes i am
a brand new minute
absolutely destroyed and then made out
with three women after that this was
your weekly appearance by hans kim
ladies and gentlemen
just a guy
doing stand-up comedy
[Music]
absolutely look how happy he is
hans wait look at answer hans is kissing
kissing the head of the girl let's see
we never know when this ends here
wait wait a second
that yeah
she's just a little shocked for a second
because i yeah
oh my god
[Laughter]
[Music]
yeah
how about a round of applause for the
band with the appropriate music
all right there they go a little bit of
prince the yellow rose and the red rose
the great hans cam
very fine
hans kim
we all live vicariously through hans i
think
someone sent me an article
someone sent me a thread from like
reddit or something like that you should
see how the incels on the internet hate
hans kim
they absolutely despise that segment why
do we have to see you making out with
girls it should who cares about that
what a job to jealous haters come to a
live show and you'll hear the crowd go
[ __ ] wild
you can feel it
hans you made out with three girls last
week on this stage how does that make
you feel it makes me feel like a sexual
god right exactly thank you so much uh
how does that make you feel making out
with three girls it makes me feel
invincible
it does do you feel like it gives you
fuel every week it feels like i can get
rejected by everyone this whole week
because i know monday is coming
well i know a lot of people there's a
lot of in-cells that absolutely hate
this segment of this show but you know i
just simply cannot help myself i have to
ask like i do every week are there any
girls that want to come up and make out
with hans kim here tonight
will never i will never stop letting
this man live his wildest dreams
wow look at this
oh [ __ ] that's a real girl whoa
[Applause]
damn
[Music]
that's not even one of the yellow rose
red rose girls
that's a real that's a real girl here
you go
show the audience what you got kiss me
another face wow
damn look at that
[Laughter]
[Music]
holy [ __ ] look at that alabama whirly
from true romance is here everybody
huns these aren't even the strippers
from the yellow rose red rose these are
real girls they look like they're from
round rock or something
these girls have like real fathers and
[ __ ] here this is incredible well sorta
i don't know about the second one
hans how do you feel
i feel like i really deserve this
i feel like this is like so
so real
we're real people we connected
we have a connection
okay the girls how how is hans as a
kisser yeah good question
um he's okay
what could he do better what what
what could he do better let's help him
so let's help
what did you know i feel like he's had a
lot of practice over the last few weeks
and if he doesn't have it yet
you can
damn
all right let's talk to uh marilyn
manson's stun double here for a second
uh
i'm just kidding you're fantastic
whatever
manson stunt whatever you are you have
things pierced that i can't even fathom
uh
if you want another needle for you if
you want another needle inside of you
you should [ __ ] hans kim
[Applause]
uh
what's your story lady what did you
think about han's kiss my story i feel
like since i got my tongue pierced
i'm not a good kisser so i mean oh [ __ ]
we're both two bad kissers kissing each
other and it was
wow
real anti-climactic sorry
well can you can we help him out what
can hans do to to improve yeah does it
need to be slower more supple lips
he can't change his lips no not like
that not like that like that
more natural what do you do for work
me yeah i'm a server oh okay
all right any cool place like like
applebee's what are you doing
how about you what do you do for work
this one over here i'm a scribe at a
hospital a scrub
what
a scribe
i just write doctor's notes oh okay not
anything like the prescriptions
i didn't know yeah yeah
all right
well i love it hans how do you feel
about this this is the first time your
kissing's been judged publicly
i feel like this is the fire that i need
to step up my game
like next week i'm gonna come at i'm
gonna practice with my pillow
i can't i can't let this happen again
i'm actually embarrassed wow and this is
this is the motivation thank you
i love it
getting better every single week
[Applause]
hans i love it is there anything else
you want to say
uh
do you feel fulfilled because last week
it was three girls is that okay yeah
totally
these are beautiful ladies and i just
i'm all about the yellow rose red rose
is there anyone up there that wants to
[ __ ] come down and make out with hans
real quick
let's see what happens here let's see
this is its own half of the show now
i see some movement let's just see what
happens here
you never know what's gonna i'm
christina it's a freak show this is wild
there's a global pandemic happening and
meanwhile
i'm trying to see how many people can
make out with hans kim every week
literally
he's adorable though oh we got we got
two girls three girls coming red band
why don't you just
[Laughter]
wow look at this hans
oh [ __ ] these are real girls
kiss me
oh my god look at this
look at that one
damn
han step up to that microphone
you went from two threes to three tens
look at that that's incredible
[Applause]
that's incredible hans loves math so
he's he knows what i'm talking about
here
incredible how do you feel now hans i
feel great uh
this is amazing
uh
i love it
i love look at that smile
that smile makes it all worth it when i
think about how i've been wronged by
asians in the past i look at your smile
and it makes it all worth it you know
that
my ancestors are smiling in their graves
right now i love it they are they're
very proud of you i love it and we are
too hard as a rock ladies and gentlemen
hans kim everybody
and the girls from the yellow rose red
rose the best strip club in the world
here we go we're going to keep it moving
let the show begin sort of that's really
not what the show is did he go back for
more or did i miss that no he didn't do
it normally he i love this i could watch
this all night i know me too who wants
to french hans believe it or not there's
some people that hate it
what i know
this is a great show they're like what
happened to the comedy part why am i
watching hans live his dreams i love it
i live for that [ __ ]
it's a korean soap opera how about one
more time it's only because he kills it
every week one more time for hans cam
the boy gets rewarded hans
you famously on this show every week
you've been making out with girls uh
left and right this has become a new
trademark of you a lot of people hate it
on the internet a lot of people love it
i actually posted uh
something this week with a bunch of
pictures of you making out with
different girls on this show and i was
surprised at how many people uh
felt like it seemed negative about it a
lot of people saying burpees and hpv
super spreaders yeah everybody's like
all these people on the internet are
like afraid to get sick or something
like that we're not here in texas we
don't play that [ __ ] we already have all
these that's how you get sick is living
in a bubble that's what the real science
shows that's true thank you alex jones
that's absolutely true
that's absolutely true that's the sound
of us being demonetized off youtube uh
this episode everybody that's right we
should all live in a bubble
and do whatever foul she says
dollar signs
[Laughter]
but hans you haven't gotten sick or
anything from any of these kisses right
if anything you love it they heal you
right yeah we're transmitting the
disease of love
red rose yellow rose come on down
they actually uh they have been last
week there was a hot dog eating contest
[Laughter]
many many dogs
[Music]
i don't know what that means but uh
seems hilarious right there at that
point
no sexual connotations
[Laughter]
i love it but he's asian so it's a
vienna sausage
[Music]
oh now we're being politically correct
it's a tootsie roll hey i have the
largest i have a micro penis so i can
make the joke
it's the largest micro penis in north
america though
asian below those go oh they go wow
look at those little balloons you know
that that's what your dick's like
show us your i'm just joking
all right uh
so hans
i'm black from the west now
oh my god i love it
hans uh how do you feel about this
making out with different girls thing
every week let's let's really just find
out from you how you feel about it i
feel like it's a great tradition and
you like it let me ask you this do you
prefer because sometimes it's it's
normal homegrown texas girls that come
up and make out with you and sometimes
like alex said it's the strippers from
the yellow rose and the red rose do you
have a preference do you have a
preference to natural or uh
whatever that is up there i mean we we
did find out that he's kissed like the
same girl three three weeks in a row
maybe stormy is very beautiful um i love
i love the organic homegrown you know
like whole foods but i also love like f1
you know formula one racing [ __ ]
ferraris and mustangs yeah
yeah takes all different types
so you know gilligan's island do you
like ginger or marianne
marianne
is that a yeah i like marianne
personally myself as well
okay
i love it
uh are there any ladies in the audience
that want to come up and make out with
hans kim tonight is there anyone that
wants to do it he's a young asian
comedian living his dreams if there is
great if not great it doesn't really
matter come on come on come on come on
it's up to you
let's talk a little more
oh look at this one all right
whoa
holy [ __ ]
this is incredible we've seen this
before
and she ain't bad looking let's see how
it goes for hans this better be a real
make-out session though
whoa
wow look at him go
oh there
hold on a second you stay over there
this
seems like there's real love in the air
over here i've never seen hans
look at this little boy
look at how excited you are hans can you
even speak right now
i think she has a thinner waist than me
thinner oh she's ready to go
did you like a chicken wow did you say
thinner yeah okay what did most girls
what is
most girls have a bigger waist than you
most girls on tinder that i can get oh i
gotcha
i got it
uh young lady what's your name
hannah
hannah
hannah hannah
hannah benny hannah hannah is this your
first time making out with an asian boy
actually it is how did it feel how did
it make you feel it was really good i've
always liked asian boys but they've
never liked me i thought it was the
other way around they just don't date
white women oh yeah well right now
there's three hard nips on this stage so
hans what do you think is there a chance
you want to go out with this girl would
you go out on a date with hans kim
yeah i would
wow now did you know about this part of
the show were you like a fan of the show
i did i did know and you were looking
forward to this did you come with like a
boyfriend or something no she came with
her sisters did you come to bag bag him
tonight
um obviously that's what i'm doing up
here
would you say bang bang
bagging pick him up take him out over
his shoulder you know like a jaguar
[Laughter]
we are not out letting alex touch the
sound board tonight gay frogs gay frogs
[Laughter]
all right all right put it away put it
away
put it away oh no
oh
no
not the rooster oh getting hungry
hans kim this is more fun than when i'm
drunk i'm usually here drunk
yeah alex jones is sober right now first
time in 25 years
alex jones making it happen
all right so uh hans i feel good about
it you did another new minute you made
out with the uh with the how do you feel
about this girl
i feel like she's very beautiful and i'd
be privileged to spend some time with
her
all right that's it
this is it this is the autistic dating
game with hans kim everybody how about
one more time for hans kim everyone
there he goes
there goes the great hannah
is it hannah yeah give it up for hannah
there goes hannah
so your girlfriend dumped you this week
let me just remind you now that we know
that you're happy and energized
uh so what do you think should you make
out with somebody you still want to do
that yes all right whoa you know let me
just say before we do the drum roll let
me just say
every single week i ask if a beautiful
woman wants to come up and kiss hans kim
i want to change things up a little bit
this week a little something
a little something for the podcast
listeners that hate this part of this
show i'm going to ask if there's a girl
out there mediocre looking uh
you don't even have to be good looking
if you feel like not so pretty today
and like
you know
you have an outbreak
wait is this a good idea during a
pandemic to pass around an asian guy
kurt we're already 12 episodes into this
uh
everybody get their own asian game
the bad news is that we've already done
it why ponds down when you're done with
him
i've had coven 17 times now
sorry anyway uh
for an autistic guy you think his
numbers jokes would be better but
an asian autistic hans what do you think
about me
what do you think about me asking if a
mediocre girl wants to make out with you
i think that's wonderful because they
have like you know they need it
more oh
there you go
[Applause]
come on are there any are there any half
half half good looking girls or do i
have to ask for a beauty is it only like
a beautiful girl only thing come on
sixes or lower if anyone wants to
come up and make out with hans if you
think you're a six or lower oh also how
could i forget this
you get one of these if you do it
and i kiss hans kim official t-shirt
the kill tony logo on the back
asian style font i believe it's called
uh i believe that's the uh
wingdings
i'm not sure what it is
the good thing about kissing me is after
you kiss me you're still hungry for more
oh god
it's so stupid
it's unbelievable i love it a call back
to something that didn't work the first
time i love it very rarely do you see
that in comedy where people go back to
it
oh can i also just say i forgot to say
but during your rendition of creep i
noticed a couple of like the tough guy
fans in the audience uh
this undercover cop at the edge here
talking to hulk hogan's ex-wife you see
this guy
not paying attention to the show at all
still has no idea that i'm talking about
him
but anyway he was literally crying
during your rendition of creep it was
unbelievably hilarious hopefully he
listens to this podcast in a couple
weeks when it comes out and here's
everything that i just said about him
he's literally still
still just talking a serial
killer murderer just sitting there
trying to put it together
he's got his kill tony bingo card out
well he's on to us all right is anyone
making out with hans i don't think it's
happening how many single women are here
because maybe you didn't put it out very
well
i don't think i deserve it this week
hans here you go take a shirt dude
thank you ironically the first week that
you don't have a girlfriend no one wants
to come out and make out with you
maybe open it up to beautiful women i
don't know i just feel bad for hans
right now i mean you shouldn't feel bad
you should watch the last 10 episodes
yeah
yeah it's crazy hans an unbelievable
performance a great song
[Applause]
wait a second
hold on just a minute
wait a second hold on a second hold on
hold on hold on everybody stop wait a
second you said a six or lower wait hans
correct me if i'm wrong but isn't this
the girl that dumped you
oh yes
wow
oh what a hero come up to the microphone
for a second what's your name
this is raph girl paige paige okay
uh and you were dating hans kim for how
long would you say uh like a month wow
like what were some of the highlights of
dating hans like when you look back and
you have like flashbacks to what
getting fingered at whataburger uh all
right great man
that's the first one that comes up
what's that what that's the first one
that comes up all right what else
um the
weird-ass trip club we went to uh where
he did not grope strippers by the way
um
river explorations multiple times uh
jeez i see why hans isn't that sad that
you dumped him
it's about as boring as it gets over
here no what made you uh what made you
finally put the kibosh on [ __ ] hans
this week
uh
i just had a divorce finalized and
i
don't want to date it but it's not what
what about finalize you just had a what
a
divorce oh [ __ ]
look at that hans the [ __ ] uh what
did they call that the uh the rebound oh
wow
killed
the rare asian rebound
not since like what jeremy lin or
something have we seen are we on an army
base or something
a very special kill tony
the divorced woman a
so hans was your rebound so all of a
sudden you go from this happy marriage
next thing you know you're getting
banged in the back of a van by an asian
guy
cops are knocking on the window
uh
so what do you think is you think
there's still a chance for hans are you
gonna least bang him every once in a
while are you gonna be a good uh friend
with benefits or is it just your
emotions i broke it off a week ago he
still came to san antonio with his
friends and uh
may or may not have
got some while we were there i did
hey
hell yeah
so yeah i get i guess what i'm really
asking what made you come here tonight
you still uh we're still friends we're
friends
we have fun it sounds like codependency
is what made up
yeah it does
sounds like god divorced can't be alone
for five minutes yeah whoa whoa once you
once here's where the relationship's
going down a river into a sharp stick
[Laughter]
[Applause]
looked pretty hot though that kiss right
it was passionate it was hans is
famously a good kisser everybody says
that it's incredible
he's got a very special tongue
is that true is he does he ever has he
ever performed oral sex on you
wow does he do anything different that
uh
how does he do what if you had to
describe the way hans genuinely the best
person that's done it wow
look at that
[Applause]
that's incredible
that's incredible let me ask you this
are you hungry for more tongue when
you're after you have it once
when he eats your [ __ ] does he use
chopsticks
oh come on man
come on man does he ever try to put it
in one of those boxes with the metal
wire oh come on
i want to take it home with me no but i
did think the soy sauce was weird oh you
saw a [ __ ] i haven't heard jokes like
that since i had to go up after a man
named
everybody
i was
what is hans the whole thing like the
whole time we talk about hans
yeah no no this is just a ridiculously
long sake
you're actually right i'm gonna get him
out of here ladies and gentlemen hans
kim and his ex-girlfriend paige
everybody you just like went through a
hole no you're right i i i just that
took up a whole romantic comedy worth of
time
the whole he played guitar then the girl
ran up
it really is i should just do another we
should do another episode of kill tony
once a week where it's just haunted yeah
the soccer porn for an hour and a half
all right hans are you do you even want
to make out with anyone this week kind
of
is there anyone in the audience who if
if a normal girl comes up here you get a
i kissed hans kim uh
t-shirt a kiltoni logo on the upper
back incredible stuff
uh so now i must ask is there a lady out
there that wants to come up and uh make
out with hans kim real quick
if you want to you can you get a shirt
hans kim like hans kim likes making out
with girls so i let him live his dreams
every week
for a while there we had uh too many
strippers coming down uh
then i found out on the show that uh
they got free what was it they have to
they don't have to pay their house fees
usually strippers have to pay 10 to the
club
but it turns out if you make out with
hans kim you don't have to give 10
percent to the
strip club that you work at these lips
are worth money
come on there must be some lady out
there that wants to come up and give
hans kim a big kiss is there a hero out
there in the audience tonight
everybody loves this segment of the show
all right who among you is dumb enough
to have this on the internet forever
well hans i don't know dude
man this this has to hurt a little bit
dude
how do you
how do you feel knowing that your run of
making out with random chicks every
monday is coming to an end right now uh
i'm kind of relieved
oh [ __ ]
what is this
whoa
wow
[Applause]
holy [ __ ]
wow and he hands her the mic right away
straight to second base with this one
wow okay i didn't know oompa loompas had
nurses but this is so exciting
i'm kidding i'm kidding you're an
american hero you came up and made out
with hans
what's your name bella bella bella when
did your dad die
i have a lot of daddy issue jokes i just
wanted a 60-second set
i thought you said no strippers
uh bella um uh have you ever made out
with an asian man before i actually
honestly haven't how did that feel how
did it feel uh is there anything
different or uh i felt like i'm gonna
have to see him like three times a week
for that i was like that's a lot we do
comedy together so i was like
why not oh okay
all right okay give the microphone back
to hans
now that i know you're a comedian let's
give it back to uh give her back the old
little hanzi over here uh hans you see
you've been working with her for weeks
months
months and uh you guys see each other
regularly yeah how did it make you feel
making out with her it was hotter
hotter than hotter than what like
there's something on the line like
this could go wrong this could go bad
yeah you might end up in a relationship
you got that nine-month law now in texas
also you need to like really think about
what the [ __ ] are you talking about the
abortion law
so what are you guys talking about what
are you guys having your own little side
conversation there why am i always
making out with guys on this show the
second time oh really you've done this
before i get bored in the cow pins so
i'm just like you know wow
did they call it a cow pen
is that a thing okay
all right
i always i thought i heard bullpen
before i didn't know a cow pen
was a thing that might be that might be
a texas thing too it's gender inclusive
all right
i like it
that's true
i love it well thank you bella thank you
hans let's keep the show moving oh you
guys making all right
[Laughter]
he didn't know what to do with his hands
everybody
one more time for hans kim
can't help it i can't help myself
[Applause]
it's becoming involved jay-z are here
one of my favorite restaurants in town
what is it becoming a fetish to you
watch hans make out with women now yeah
it's a real fetish yes indeed nothing
gets me off more than watching an asian
man awkwardly make out with a stranger
you're right